so what prize are we playing for you ask
wait what about me nobody picked my
envelope
so what prize are we playing for you ask
oh the infinity gauntlet from the
avengers yes
except not quite the actual movie
replica was extremely expensive so i had
to get something off russian ebay say
hello to
the infinitude gobbler it's identical to
the one that
sabu wore in the movie of venga boys
this glove gobbler
contains three plastic jewels the
infinitive gems
each representing one aspect of a heist
winner amazing human
genius whoever possesses these stones at
midnight
will be named champion but what
obstacles will i face you may ask
yourself well
the infiniti gems will be guarded by a
ferocious and daunting sentry
hey best friend we're not your best
friends bill you don't get to decide
that
so bill will hide the gems in his
pockets you're really gonna have to root
around in there
i dried my jeans so they're extra tight
you were right amy i should have got a
safe sorry everyone let the heist begin
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
valentine's day halloween heist
this is still happening why so curious
terry hoping we'll let you participate
now
cause you can't oh no i don't get to
compete for a bunch of stones that were
in a dog's butt what will i do
i'll have you know that a dog's butt is
cleaner than a human's mouth that can't
be true well
a dog's mouth is cleaner than a human's
mouth and dog mouths lick dog butts so
you tell me where my theory is wrong
feels no comeback all right the heist
will pick up where we left off there are
six hours remaining and three teams left
the now
sterilized infinititude gems will be
placed back into the care of bill
oh wow bill looks like he had a rough
four months it was actually a great
three months and then one really bad one
okay but you're here and you're happier
than ever
i don't know why you think that let the
high stream begin
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
easter valentine's day halloween heist
we will once again pick up where we left
off the infinitude gym
guys are still doing this you know it's
april now yeah terry we're still doing
it and we're still having a great time
why are the gems so pale i guess
scully's inside sapped all the color out
of them i don't know babe you're
undercutting my whole thing with terry
here
anyways the infiniti gems will go back
to bill
whose life seems to have unraveled even
further tough march for you there bud
yeah just a heads up i sold my pants
with the pocket so i'll be putting the
gems
in my undies this time no i'll give him
a fanny pack can i keep it
this could be just what i need to turn
my life around yeah belt you can keep
the panty back i don't have to do
anything for it do i
because i well if you ask i'll do
anything even
what's that supposed to represent no one
answer that
you